you know that's the funny thing about
physics and biology
the dream of physicists in the 20th
century and maybe this century is to
discover the theory of everything
and there's a sense by
that once you discover that theory you
will understand everything
if we unlock the mysteries of how the
universe works would you be able to
understand
how life emerges from that fabric of the
universe that we understand i think the
phrase theory of everything is very
misleading
because it's used to describe a theory
which unifies the um three
laws of microphysics electricity
magnetism and weak interaction with
gravity so it's
important step forward for particle
physicists
but the lack of such a theory doesn't
hold up any other scientists
anyone doing biology or most of physics
is not held up at all
through not understanding subnuclear
physics they're held up because they're
dealing with things that are very
complicated
and that's especially true of anything
biological so what's holding up
biologists
is not a lack of the so-called theory of
everything
it's the
inability to understand things which are
very complicated
what do you think will understand first
how the universe works or how the human
body works
deeply like from a fundamental deep
level well i think um perhaps we can
come back to it later that there
are
only limited prospects of ever
being able to understand with unagi as
human brains the most fundamental
theories linking together all the forces
of nature i think that may be a
limitation of the human brains
but i also
think that
we can perhaps aided by computer
simulations
understand a bit more of the complexity
of nature
but even understanding a simple organism
from the atom up is very very difficult
and i think extreme reductionists
have a very misleading perception they
tend to think that uh
in a sense we are all solutions as far
as equation etc
but that
isn't the way we ever understand
anything
it may be true that we
are reluctant in a sense if we believe
that that's the case we don't believe in
any special life force in living things
but nonetheless no one thinks that we
can understand a living thing by solving
certain
to take an example which isn't as
complicated lots of people study the
flow of fluids like water
why waves break why flows go turbulence
things like that this is a serious
branch of applied mathematics and
engineering and in doing this you have
concepts of viscosity turbulence and
things like that
now
you can understand quite a lot about how
water behaves and how waves break
in terms of those concepts
but the fact that any
breaking wave is a solution
of frederick's equation for tens of 30
particles
even if you could solve that which you
clearly can't would not give you any
insight so the important thing is that
every science has its own irreducible
concepts
in which you get the best explanation
so it may be in chemistry it's things
like valence um in
biology the
concept in cell biology
and in ecology there are concepts like
imprinting etc and in psychology there
are other concepts so in a sense the
sciences are
like a tall building
where you have
basic physics the most fundamental then
the rest of physics then chemistry then
cell biology etc
all the way up to the i guess economist
and the penthouse and all that um and we
have that um
and that's true in a sense but it's not
true
that it's like a building in that it's
made
unstable by an unstable base because if
you're a chemist biologist or an
economist
you're facing challenging problems
but they're not made any worse
by uncertainty about sub-nuclear physics
and at every level just because you
understand the rules of the game or have
a some understanding of the rules of the
game doesn't uh
mean you know
what kind of beautiful things that game
creates
right so uh if you're interested in um
birds and how they fly uh then things
like
imprinting
the baby on the mother and all that and
uh things like that are what you need to
understand um you couldn't even in
principle
solve this vertical equation how an
albatross wanders for thousands of miles
of the southern ocean and comes back and
then coughs up food for its young uh
that's something we can understand in a
sense and predict the behavior but it's
not because we can solve it on the
atomic scale
you